[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and so this is what we can pick up the
slides and we'll leave that one up
quickly and we have one at the end as
well as you complete this the slides up
from our website as well as some of the
other blog posts that we have around
this particular interesting topic so
this is what I'm going to go through
today we have an introduction more more
likely about who we are what we do then
we're going to talk about the different
data formats to apply I'm not going to
any really any depth into them because
it for a 35 minute talk you really can't
get into too much depth but we're going
to cover the majority of them then we're
a still business 83 how to choose them
and we've actually done some
benchmarking on some of these the thing
I'd like to point out straight off the
bat is we did this about a year ago and
we haven't got back to as a consulting
company we have clients and
unfortunately sometimes the clients get
in the way of us doing the really
interesting work I can't really say that
myself persons in the room but we will
get back to that some stuff that we want
to talk about then I'll dig into the
idea of schema evolution and then
storage choices which is mainly around
things like do I use direct storage do I
use object stores or my in the cloud
what do I do and how does that affect
and then obviously some questions at the
end so let me start with some
introductions so we're a boutique data
science data engineering consulting
company based in Mountain View but we
have offices in Chicago Bentonville
Arkansas and London as well as people
dotted around the country we're about 65
to 70 people in total so these are some
of our how we want to put it our
thoughts of the thoughts mission
statement vision statement as it were
you know we work as cross-functional
teams have been dead of engineering and
data science so I'm the VP of data
engineering there is a VP of data
Sciences my counterpart we have
engineering teams and data science teams
but we actually work really well
together
and we work as a blended team for our
clients so we use agile software
development approaches we make rapid
progress against difficult problems and
require flexibility
but the really important one in there is
we want to get to business values as
quickly as possible hence the add agile
methodology around it to iterate towards
the larger goal so the idea is we won't
come in and say hey doesn't take six
months at the end of six months we show
you something it's every two weeks we'll
show you something and pivot from there
that's enough about what we do is
Silicon Valley data science let's go
into the the meters amount of the data
formats so this is a little timeline
actually spend some time trying to find
out when these actually happened so we
reckon around 2006 and I think he may be
in a little bit before this because I
was working at Yahoo when Doug cutting
and those guys are they're doing Hadoop
was when text files and sequence files
came into use within the platform then
around 2008 we had our C files then 2009
we have arrow files obviously coming out
of Doug cutting and all those guys
looking at row probably a lot of it came
from what Google was doing and what
Facebook was doing as well and then in
2013 as Julian was up here is the I
guess the father of parquet so we have
Park a van
I win O'Malley over at Hortonworks was
doing oh I see as well so we've seen a
change of where things are going and the
other one is is where is the future
going I know there was probably possibly
some talks around arrow as well which is
kind of an interesting concept and how
that kind of fits into this ecosystem to
just get the text
so basically text files are anything
that's human readable right so some CSV
files back in my day CSV files back in
my day that's what I always in you know
pulled into Oracle way back when cs3
Jason when it comes around we just had a
client where we're pulling in a massive
XML file and I forgot how XML was
absolutely a nightmare but we did it so
these are different formats really easy
to read easy to exchange the main thing
is it's human readable so I can just
pull up and read it and like oh yeah
that looks right that doesn't cry
but these data stores are bulky and
inefficient to query all right we can
use potentially things like Apache drill
to query xml and json files but i plays
a kind of bulky to query but it don't
support broad compression you can
compress the file but when I want to
pull that into Hadoop it has to kind of
read it and decompose itself and then
push it up or to other mappers if I'm
doing something like a hive query or in
some cases in parler well when I move
things around then we had sequence files
that came out so it came out at the same
time so this is a binary file you know
key value pairs is rope still robe a so
it's on the row based thing we haven't
hit the column area
call me comment condom Italy common
Milly kana merely used mainly between
MapReduce jobs so that as well as the
idea that if I've got MapReduce job and
these things are talking to each other
we may pull in text files initially but
then the communication between these
things would actually be sequence files
mainly because it can handle the broad
compression and I can actually separate
these files and it's in the binary
format and it's obviously a lot faster
and as I said before it's it supports
principle splitting even when the data
is compressed so if I've got a compress
sequence files I'm putting into a
MapReduce job or a I guess a hive query
Impala etc it can split them up and then
give them to the right data nodes right
to do the query pieces on those data
nodes and kind of assemble the contents
back together again look at Avro Arrow
hopefully chili inside in the room is
actually one of my favorites and I
really like Avro used a lot in
Civilization if anyone's being using
confluent or caf-co and using confluent
and using a schema registry that's all
in Avro I like the idea that I can
describe the schema
I've got schema evolution which we come
on to later I just it's actually really
nice but the problem is it and we'll see
shortly it doesn't perform particularly
well anymore
the cool thing is the scheme was encoded
in the file which is great where I can
actually look at the far to see what the
schemer is does this does support bra
compression and spreadable and like I
said before it does have scheme
evolution and we've got a little section
of schema evolution as well which is
from an old database guy
I love schema evolution right Parkay and
blending genes in the room so if I get
something wrong he can't tell me off so
now we get into the column er oriented
data stores the data files right so it's
a binary one we've got use record
shredding assembly algorithms described
in the dremel paper so perfect each data
file consists of valleys for a set of
rows efficiency in terms of i/o which is
actually really important but the main
one is a lot of this is it's common
lemma based so when you have a really
really wide table which still we will
get to in a minute ways that's where it
comes into its its case of why you would
want to use it and in some cases you
kind of use it all the time but not this
still Silvius Thunder then we have
optimized row column ax or I will call
it o RC from now on it's the evolution
of the us D arcy file as well as like
parquet also is column ax the other one
as well has is a really good compression
algorithm and actually compresses a lot
better when we were looking at this a
year and a half ago
better than Park a while so if storage
is an issue oh I'll see files are really
good to compress the other one is well
it does come with some basic stats from
the columns I'm in max Ehrmann coun
within the file which is kind of
interesting
which parquet at the time doesn't do and
again as we get into doing a new a newer
version of this we look at the newer
versions of parquet for instance but
again suitable for parallel processing
Road collection now with saying that I'm
going to pass over to Silvia who's
McGann to the meat of the the details
and watch isn't it work what is going to
do is actually walk through some of the
testing they'll benchmarking that we did
on these different formats using
different query engines and in some
cases also different ecosystems as well
so Sylvia Thank You Stuart okay so I
think it's the fun part at least for me
is how did you choose which data format
to use and it changes a lot depending of
your starting or if you already have
like all your data link and everything
so I want to start with there's no
Universal answer there's no single
answer I'm gonna give you be like oh
yeah I need to use that one so instead
of when I give you a framework and I'm
going to give you questions that you can
ask yourself so you can choose what's
best for your own data platform so let's
start with what we talked the functional
requirements are which are just basics
let's talk about what type of data you
have like are you pulling your data from
an application
do you have log files which is what
Stephen was talking about CSDs so it
depends what kind of data you have and
then what kind of then the next question
is like what kind of tools do you have
that you already know you're going to
use a Hadoop cluster so you know you
want to use hive and Impala so do they
support the data format that you want to
use we'll see in the next slide exactly
which Curie engine support which data
formats another question that you might
ask yourself is like what about my data
sizes do I have lots of little files so
I have lots of big files am i concerned
about the spacing my cluster and other
thing and the last one again Stephen
already talked about a little bit about
this is a scheme evolution
I might worry that my data is going to
change over time so for example you have
an app and you're downloading the files
from the app but then you know next
month your app might change in my add a
new field how's that going to play
around with what you had already so how
do you reconcile what you your data used
to look like to data that has a new
column and so on and then I'm going to
talk about how do you choose files for
writing use cases and reading use cases
so let's firstly take a look about the
Curie engines and which data format they
support and of course this is not a
comprehensive list this is just a list
that we have right now so right now hive
supports all the data formats that we
talk about text sequence a proportion or
RC let's see how the Impala Impala
doesn't support or C so this is a
perfect example where you're like oh I
want to use or RC but then you cannot
curate if you're planning to using
Impala
so that might influence your decision
for drill the main ones are text and
parquet and the other ones there you can
read there are text formats but they are
not fully supported it sparks equal
convert everything right now and then
presto doesn't have full support for
Abra Reiner okay so let's move into the
use cases about how do you choose a data
format when writing data is your main
concern so again this fits a little bit
with what I was talking about the
functional requirements which is a are
you concerned about the spirit are you
concerned about the memory are you
concerned about the scheme evolution
what about percept can you parse the
data or is the data easily inspectable
so if you have a lot of analyzed I just
want to let go and look at the data like
they probably want to see text right
they don't want to have to use a cue
Union to be able to translate what they
see on the file so what we did and this
is the fun part is we run a bunch of
tests I don't want to call them
benchmarks because we use different
systems and each system has a different
footprint so one quarter was a smaller
than the other but we came up with
choose sets of data so two data sets the
first one is what we call or narrow data
set which is 10 million rows and only 10
columns so this is kind of like similar
what an Apache love look like so when
you want to go on B to the website and
it records all your information and then
we have a what we call a white data set
which is formalin rows and this one has
1000 columns so
think about your pulling some user data
and then you're saving choices so a
thousand columns of those user choices
or user data it's important to add that
for most of our data formats we compress
them using snappy
except for abra we were also trying
deflate so if there's a label in our
graph such as deflate then you know
that's that's the only one that we try
both of them for now so for the ring
test we only use hive and we're using
two distributions of Hadoop one of them
is Claira and the other one is
Hortonworks
so let's start with Hortonworks which
had hives 0.14 at the time that we did
the tests and this is just measuring the
writing speed so you have your time and
then your data format so on the left
side is a narrow one and you can see
text in sequence right pretty fast and
all the other farmers are a bit slower
this is because they have to start doing
all the formats for example in a
columnar format you will have to
separate the columns and write in
different blocks we have a kind of like
a cool diagram in the website that shows
you how the data formats are written in
blocks so if you want to look at that
later it's cool
um just add on to that one silvia is
even we got the timing here we actually
have done this with other clients as
well and what we actually see is the
graphs look the same so regardless of
the size of cluster and how long it took
the actual graphs looked the same
so obviously tax is always the fastest
end sequence files then it becomes Avro
then it's basically Park in our scene is
it kind of looks like that across the
board there very interesting we just
took the time away or even say how big
the data sets were within reason you
need at least something that's you know
in the inner terms of gigabytes and
hundreds of them but the actual graphs
are look exactly the same and to that
point if we move on to the cloud era
distribution again it's different system
different sizing of the system but the
graph pretty much looks the same
when it's a narrow dataset there's not
much difference but when you're starting
to use wider wider datasets just when
you say the pronounce difference so
that's in terms of speed
what about sighs how much size do this
data formats take on my system this the
cool part so as we know : our formats
are being are able to compress very well
especially it that's also going to pet
this ratio is going to depend on the
kinds of data that your columns are
storing so for example if a lot of your
columns are just boolean or integers
they're going to be able to compress
more than if they have like text or a
bar chart or something like that so
these ratios actually bar I depending on
your data but text and sequence files
are very bulky they take the most space
when you stir them your system approach
is in the middle of the pack but then
again Mark A and/or C compress really
well or CLE with better number K but
that's okay so we're going to move to
one let's just recap what I just talked
about so in terms of writing when did
you choose to use text okay you choose
to use text when you want to write your
data really fast and when you want to
make it personal by anybody like anybody
you can just come and take a look at the
file and open it and see what's going on
a sequence file we only recommend it if
you're really still doing my produced
jobs as Steven said it's like the
transition between one MapReduce job and
the other one every we recommend when it
enters the schema evolution and the
corner formats like party on our C we'll
see about this because right now you saw
that they compress very well they take a
little bit longer to cried but it's
going to be a trade of everything's like
a trade of innovative world so while
they took longer to cry they compress
better and they're going to be faster to
read which is where we're going to look
at or news next if case that is how do
you choose your data format when you're
more concerned about
getting results faster all right so
again we start with a water concerns I
think there's different types of curious
that you can run in a system so some of
them are very specific columns like I
want to know demographics or I want to
know a specific thing about a user so
they're very targeted generally look up
certain columns for each record and then
there's curious where you're like give
me all the data for this user or for
this set of users so you're looking at
two completely different things so we're
going to see in the next graph does like
the trade of where their rate
performance is better even though the
files took longer to write so again we
have our data sets that we're testing so
we have the same er the narrow dataset
the Y dataset but this time we wanted to
push the limits away with more and we
enlarge the white data set so still a
thousand columns but we run it as long
as to create like one terabyte of data
so that's what we're going to be curing
and again everything is compressed using
snappy and then except for Abra which we
do a snappy and deflate so this time
we're using hive to Curie Impala and
we're since Park and this time our
systems are we use a quadratic tribution
of Hadoop and we use Amazon EMR and it's
important like we mentioned what a
peculiar you running so we run four
types of Curie's the first one is just a
regular account the second one is like a
Curie dahut five conditions or five were
classes for different columns the test
series ten conditions and the fourth
Curie is twenty conditions
okay so let's start with that claw data
distribution and start looking at hive
which is kinda like the baseline for a
lot of things so when you have your
narrow data set
everything looks kind of like home
together there's not a clear difference
on which data format is better except
for a birdie flight which is not
performing so hot compared to the other
ones and at the beginning we were like
well this is not what we expect them
this is not what we saw in previous
versions of hive so it's something that
we wanted to we put a halt to go and
investigate it a later date the other
one to add on this one is query one
isn't on there because for every single
format of data format that we had
because it was running this version of
hive is here to get account regardless
it was already cached so it's always
like zero seconds it come back pretty
much immediately that's why it on this
particular chart so now let's move to
our data sets so let's look at the white
data set and this is where you start
seeing the difference in performance
within the different data formats so
your columnar formats are much faster at
curing when there's a specific
conditions right so our C / K then you
have sequence tags and again Avro is
kind of like there are called child
right now that is not performance at all
and then when we move to or one turn of
ID that's it that's when you really see
like a difference and the scale
sometimes it's kind of like misleading
but Averett talk like four times as long
as security tests and/or see your upper
care file and even text took like three
thousand seconds as opposed to a
thousand seconds so next one we're going
to look at the same to result in Impala
first you'll notice that there's no RC
because as you saw on the previous slide
Impala was in support or Z so we really
is in the other data formats and again
this is the narrow data set so we only
have ten columns so the difference is
not that great so per case still fast
but same us a borough and the sequence
files tax is slower regardless and the
Alberta beef loads are still misbehaving
the other thing to add on here as well
that from a column of format you see
with parquet on this particular one is
the time goes up so you go from no
careers to five the amount of time goes
from one less than one second to like
1.8 seconds and then go to the ten
conditions it goes up to just over two
seconds and the same when the sequence
bar which is interesting because I would
expect that to be more level because it
so has a read pretty much all the
columns regardless the average Snap is
an interesting one where the one with
five conditions was actually took longer
than the one with ten conditions no by
the way we actually average this I think
we did like 10 20 runs of this to get
the averages out and we also kind of
think things like shut down the classes
to make sure we didn't have any
basically any caching going on either at
the file system level or actually within
Hadoop as well so one rate so it is kind
of clean as much as possible we have
some interesting things that we
definitely saw on here compared to one
that will show later on but carry on
Silvia
okay so now again when we started
looking at the wide a that said this is
when our care starts to shine right you
can see there's like clear difference
where it performs better than all the
other formats
just because we're limiting we're using
the advantages of looking at a specific
columns like Steven mentioned still kind
of like an increasing the more
conditions the more time it takes and
that's kind of like expected and our
super large data set again I arcade
chime in everything there was a weird
bump for a Baroda flight now that we
couldn't really explain but everything
else is kind of like what we expected
where average is now performing in the
middle of the pack which is what we
wanted at some point and then the text
and the sequence are not performing so
hot
so now let's take a look at again hi but
this time in an Amazon EMR because
different playlists
hello distributions you have different
enhancements in some of their curing
tools ok so again we start with our
narrow the data set and this looks again
very like compressed and like everything
there's like a little bit difference but
not too much and in fact in this one
that was funny that text and sequence
were faster than all the other ones
which is different what we saw before in
another header distribution and then
this is our white data set but then
again now that we have more columns so
we see again where we expect that our
culinary fall file formats are shining
and everything else pretty much done
yeah before you mean Soviet so this is
the interesting one is because we had
used different versions of hive it acted
with Avro very differently and this is
one of the things that I will also
reiterate at the end as well is every
time you get a new version you've got to
run the test again because what you
thought was what was going on in one
version when you change the versions
between say for instance your your
hadoop distro or your version of Avro
and potentially some storage pieces it
changes dramatically and we saw this
definitely on Avro I remember having a
discussion once with a hive committer
about why this is and he had some
thoughts around they were they were
probably not optimizing for Avro because
people things like IRC and park' came
along and they were cited optimizing for
that and changing it which caused a
problem is with Avro so when you have
clients that are using when we have
clients are using Avro and they're going
to newer versions we kind of say ok we
may make may make sense now to actually
change that to a new version because all
of a sudden you're going to see a
Leighton you know your queries are going
to increase in time which may you know
may not meet your SLA is that you have
with your with the business or the
clients yes so definitely we like to do
we like to experiment that we like to
Tufte so again this part and this was a
last year so it still spark 1.6 and this
is one of the ones that we really want
to update now with spark to you and
sporadic to one and this is actually one
of our colleagues from this test his
name is Andrew ray he's a spark
contributor so he helped us run all this
test and was here so first again we
start with our narrow dataset so only 10
columns and in this case you know how we
even show that here you one for high
because it optimizes for that so that's
not a case in spark so it's far given
for a cure with no conditions with just
account you are still seeing difference
within the data format everything is
increasing depending on the number of
conditions but again Parkay really shine
with spark and then average still kind
of like slow the other thing to add in
here is the I think the time of using
spark the orz driver so park' is a first
class citizen in spark Oh our season is
actually going through some some bits in
hive so it's kind of expected it's got
more potentially more code paths to go
through to pull the data in you know I
see than it does with park' which is an
insight that we saw straightaway like
what I'm asking Andrew why why is that
the case and he went axe you into the
spot road and said yeah the carry paths
are very different
Parkay is a first class citizen in spark
and it's so moving on a two or wide data
set and this is like where it starts to
him a little funny which we're talking
about the or C and per care because now
we have more columns they obviously are
faster than literally the formants but
the interesting part here was that first
point for or see where it takes way
longer than everything else that's
something that I think Andrew was
looking at some point and probably
thought okay
and then again our large data set this
was a Andrew playing around with this
and he was trying sparkman which caches
some of the data in the memory so it's
supposed to be faster so it's faster
even than using like the columnar data
format and this is something I'm excited
to see in the future because it's like
the same thing with our array is going
to be able to cache data or like use the
columnar format own memory that's kind
of speed up a lot of things so that's
something for the future that's
interesting so I think I love you too so
yeah so a lot of what were Sylvia did it
actually came from a client and I'm
going to put this up on the screen this
was probably a few years ago now we had
a an order version of the deep ecosystem
as well as as well as versions of things
like Parque Avro etc and this is where
we saw average deflate would actually be
really interesting so this is a customer
they're coming from an Oracle database
they want to do queries and the moment
with Oracle they only can limit
themselves to five conditions they make
inquiry on five things that's how many
indexes they wanted to create on those
conditions because they needed speed to
come through so marketing to basically
do things like taking demographic and
geographic and defining hey is this
household
what is the pendency to buy a car do
they have animals a cat is it dog how
many children do they have so basically
marketing company for a cable
advertising and they were moving to a
way like we want to query a lot faster
we can do in in Oracle we want to move
to the Hadoop type infrastructure
because we want to bring on more clients
so we actually ran a task actually I ran
the test on this one and it was actually
fun to do actually coding for a VP of
engineering is always fun and I ran it
for every single combination of
data file with compression we were using
a part of the whole thing so that's why
our season there so we did the
compression I imagine the tax
uncompressed and the Avro uncompressed
and the sequence uncompressed is
actually quite high the other things
that we notice as well is regardless of
number of conditions things I seek all
snappy texts average deflate well pretty
much the same all the time so regardless
of how many conditions I had it was
level set all the time and then we
pulled in park' and we and you can see
what it's doing obviously being a common
polymer format every condition or field
I added the latency went up which is
kind of what we expected I remember
showing this to the client and we ran
the query and the query came back for it
was five conditions the query comes back
in like seven seconds and they like the
first thing they say is Wow but you
obviously can that and we said okay well
give us another condition they got our
thousand columns to choose from so they
sat down they spray to each other for
like five minutes and came up with this
condition we put it into an parlor and
ran the query and it comes back in three
seconds so they're like blown away the
the product manager looked over to the
CTO says ok so when can we have this and
then the salesman says hey you know we
at the moment we only say that you nee
can get seven five conditions one if we
say you can get 10 conditions but it's
gonna cost you double if you want 20s
and a cost you triple and there's no
difference on the infrastructure that
they were using and it was the same so
all of a sudden it the salesman
actually got it before everyone else did
like oh I can make more money out of
this and it doesn't change now the
interesting thing was if they went up to
40 conditions and they did that on a
regular basis it actually may be better
in this case to use our very deflate
because the timing was the same and if
they went over 40 the time is still say
the same so a lot of it will depend on
your use cases of what you want to pick
on that one
so recommend recommendation recommended
formats pretty much as you saw a column
a format when you're querying specific
rows and all of them is going to always
be better there is a sweet spot and as
Sylvia was showing that sweet spot is
actually moving in the example that I
had the sweet spot was about 40 columns
in the other ones it actually goes up to
about 60 or 80 and so in some cases is
like why am I using any other format
rather than a column ER format and then
obviously if you want schema evolution
then you have Avro but then you take the
hit on query time so with that I'm going
to talk about a schema evolution now so
what is scheme evolution what data
formats evolve examples use cases and
the other thing I've added on here is
migrating from one data format to
another which is actually come up a few
times when the client goes well if I get
myself into Avro or Park a and a new
format comes along how easy is it for me
to migrate from one format to another so
schema evolution is adding columns
renaming columns or removing columns and
why do I need up so I originally slide
off in the UK and I would get I would
work in for some Microsystems I get
schemas coming over from the US and they
have the address it'd be street address
city state with two characters we don't
really have that and then they have zip
code which is basically an integer and
it's only five long because in the UK a
postal code a postal code is is about
nine and it's alphanumeric so one of the
things I would do all the time where I
get a schema coming over from the US um
Oracle developer and I have to go and
change that schema to say like actually
we don't have a zip code let's call it
postal code I make a varchar' making it
probably about ten I wouldn't remember
looking at like okay what are the rest
of the world have so we'd have to do a
schema evolution and if I'm doing that
with a really large data set in
production that can actually change how
my queries will or
because I'm going from an integer to a
to a string and the actual time it takes
to actually do it Oracle was pretty good
at doing that if I was in my sequel
doing that and I had a really large data
set it actually has to rewrite the table
and that may not be possible because
that table then is offline for read or
write access so schema evolution to me
was very important so formats I can
involve Avro is the one that is the
quote unquote gold standard of scheme
evolution and I show you an example of
that shortly Oh RC has some changes in
to one which we have a changing column
type so I can change the column type
from an integer to a number and I can
either delete or reorder columns as well
which may or may not be useful I'm not a
big one of deleting stuff that some
people are park' at the moment can only
add columns to the end and if Julian was
in the room he could correct me but the
moment is you've also got to make sure
in what order you're adding those
columns because if I add one column and
then someone adds another column to a
different file even though we've got
different column names it still has the
same index address so if you're looking
for that column in you've got your
schema saying hey you know column C is
in position 3 on one file is in position
3 but it's in position 4 in another file
I'm not going to get the one in the
other file because it is doing it by
index but not by name which actually oh
are see changed I remember having a long
discussion with Owen about that I've yet
to have it with Julian I'm sure I will
at some point so here's my arrow example
I'm a I'm a Doctor Who fan probably the
original doctor hood and the new Doctor
Who this is a data set that came from
the Guardian in 2010 about Doctor Who's
and time travel information is beautiful
it's kind of it was fun a trip me down
memory lane
but this is the avro format I'm the
schema I'm going to use this is just
defining the schema this is an aviary
schema for Doctor Who
this is the data for Doctor Who I was a
big jon pertwee
Doctor Who fan page myself so anyone
else in the room who knows who John
Pertwee is doing the same age as me and
this is some data that came from that
from that particular one this is
original Doctor Who so let's example I
want to add rename and delete some
columns so what I'm doing here is I'm
going to change the Doctor Who session
Oh change it to Doctor Who session
rather than dr. underscore who on the
school session says aliased and the same
with Doctor Who accent and I'm going to
get rid of estimated at the column and
I'm going to add a new column because in
a new Doctor Who is we've got high
definition but the default is no so
anyone who doesn't have it the default
is no so what we've done here is the
table the columns have changed and
they're still pulling the same data and
I've added HD so the new file had HD the
old file doesn't so it's in a shame now
on those and this is the same so I had
an original data format file I have the
new one and I basically put them in the
same directory for hive to query and I
got these results so basically our
schema evolution on data that's already
been there so I don't have to go rewrite
that information which is kind of cool
and I'm sure I'm getting the five
minutes and we're going to be up in a
minute so I apologize so the use case of
this is data added to an event stream so
things may be changing all the time I
got to be able to schema I got all my
schema well new data is coming in which
is what Sylvia was talking about need to
see historic data with new data when
it's changed my doctor who example
updated filled column names based on the
evolving business the business has
changed a column name you've got a
change
the new data is coming in with a new
column name some I'm going to quickly go
through this this is basically migrating
from one format to another so I'm
basically taking a text file which is s1
and making it into hey I'm going to
create data a table called s1 Avro I'm
selecting it from s1 I'm telling it I'm
using as Avro I'm compression in snappy
the same for LC the same for pod K so
it's very easy to
and from one data 1 data format to
another the other thing to note on here
we've been burned a couple of times now
make sure you always test to make sure
the data files are compressed so even
though it may say it's nappy compression
in the file name make sure it's really
snappy compression and there's ways of
checking that and this is the spark
example for the same thing it's
basically just rewriting the format as
either parquet in this case Avro or IRC
and some storage choices just running
for time so for the different storage
choices right we can either do a plain
old filesystem so basically disks are
actually on my on my node I can have a
distributed file system like HDFS or I
can have a block object store mainly
probably an object store in either s3 as
your Google or Seth from Red Hat then
the question is where is your data
center is it on pram is it in the clouds
is it public or private the reasons for
choosing these different data stores
we've seen it with a couple of customers
now that they want to spin up a frame
roll Hadoop clusters but they don't to
keep confident they don't want to keep
necessarily always computer data from
one HDFS cluster to another HDFS cluster
they want to basically pull that data
hydrate those clusters in some cases
from a common object store s3 ashes blob
googles or SAS and then be able to
actually increase their number of nodes
coming up so for instance if you want to
data science team that has some
workloads they may spin up a cluster
pull the data from the object store do
work on it and then set the results down
again the other thing as well and don't
know if we have any of our destroyed
friends in the room it limits your
licensing cost when your storage is
increasing so we've had clients as gone
hey we have about a 300 no cloud era
cluster we have more data than we can
put in a cluster we don't really want to
add more nodes to paid cloud zero more
money because we don't need to compute
we just need the storage and this is
definitely a way of looking at it
as well and I just talked about why you
want these different needs so with that
and I'm sorry I'm running over time any
question